every time that there's some sort of a
catalyst
of suffering it's just reminding you to
close the gap
between the illusory separation
and the intoxication of maya
and your person identity to re-identify
yourself as god to reunite
as god every catalyst is just trying to
fix the distortion
and the more that you turn around the
more that you unfreeze your will
and choice from the algorithms and the
scripts
that we've perpetuated with our
conditioning and
rather we sovereignly
turn inward and unite with this very
force of creation re-identify yourself
with the very
force of creation itself
i am the force of creation
i am source expressing itself
as god playing with itself
that's all you need to do
you will no longer see separate people
you will see everything as god playing
with itself
you will see everything as a divine
exploration
you will see this entire universe as an
appearance of infinity
it's that simple radically
know love and accept yourself
again radically know
love and accept yourself
and
relax the contracted identity
from the person to
god to the very source of creation
itself
if you do those two things radically
know love and accept yourself
see yourself as god sees you with that
same love
have the same love for yourself that god
has for you
because you are that there is no gap
it's an illusion but it's up to you
to disassociate yourself from the
contracted
energy of personhood towards
being god towards recognizing yourself
as
god as source as the one infinite
creator
expressing itself in this creation
so again the two things know love and
accept yourself
radically truly
unconditionally
and the second thing shift your identity
from
being a person to being god
to being the very source of creation
itself
and see everywhere you look is
all god playing with itself
everywhere is that and that is the
eradication of malevolence
that is the eradication of suffering
you will no longer inflict malevolence
because you will truly know yourself you
will truly be a gnostic being you will
know yourself as
source as the one infinite creator
expressing itself and you will see
the one infinite creator source god
everywhere you look
playing with itself you'll come
from there rather than coming from your
person conditioning
you will come from god you will come
from a pure place of
serving your own creation
that's as simple as we can get
spirituality
know love and accept yourself and
identify
yourself as god as
source not as the person
you